[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
are there like trials or any movie do me
a favor
can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
just stay close to the ground you you're
the spider-man from you too can you
summon anomaly exploiters oh yeah no no
I happen to still can I try to soon on
the rich and the powerful like stark
they don't care about the world's change
in voice time we changed too
he's looking for crazy dangerous mr.
Tator forget the flying monster day
there are people who handle the sweeping
Eureka weapons Barry was a 230 you
missed it
[Music]
what if somebody died I was just trying
to be like you I want you to be better
I'm gonna need the suit back
well nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything
protect my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
I don't mess with
I'll kill you and everybody new blow
a guy is still out there I just got to
do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
you